hi I'm Erik Bosse and as we count down
the days to the next Avengers movie one
big Marvel mystery has emerged after
Thanos who's next now sure might be a
little premature to start measuring the
drapes with Thanos while he's still very
much the reigning champ
but we have gotten some major clues that
a new threats beyond the mad Titan is
looming through over old man there's a
new evil puppy we want to play with but
who is it future MCU villains have been
brought up before but it really depends
on what general narrative direction
Marvel wants to go for phase 4 really I
see your big directions I'm gonna break
down each one and look at these recent
hints to suggest who the next villain
could be spoiler warning in cases any of
these predictions into being right okay
when looking ahead to Marvel phase 4 the
elephant in the room is Disney's
upcoming merger with Fox Studios soon
Disney's Marvel Studios will regain the
film rights to Fox's Marvel properties
x-men the Fantastic Four Deadpool many
others so the first big direction I see
Marvel phase 4 going rebooting the Fox
Marvel villains the best version of this
is I think we can all agree a reboot of
Doctor Doom Doctor Doom is one of the
smartest and most dangerous threats
throughout the Marvel Comics and
unfortunately is two major screen
adaptations to date I haven't really
done him justice fans are desperate for
a version of him done right and in a
Marvel phase four that reintroduces the
x-men and Fantastic Four two spider-man
The Avengers and the guardians of the
galaxy it could be the perfect setup for
Doctor Doom to wreak havoc and he's not
the only great villain from this side of
the Marvel world who would now be able
to take over the show magneto apocalypse
Dark Phoenix these are all super
powerful villains whom we've seen before
or in some cases we'll see again and if
they're rebooted it could threaten the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in all new
interesting ways like imagine if the
adventures of spider-man the others
realize mutants exist among their world
there would now be a lot more enhanced
adventures running around and now they
would have to deal with some zealots
among these mutants trying to militarize
mutant kind now yes it's essentially the
plot in magneto and apocalypse have
tried to carry out before but trust me
it would be a lot more fun if spider-man
and Iron Man and the Hulk are all mixed
up in this conflict the Fox Marvel
lineup also includes some cosmic forces
that could be brought into the MCU
characters like the Silver Surfer an
Iowa
and blackness who could pose apocalyptic
threats to this universe as much as
Spanos did but if Marvel wants to
essentially expand the cosmic side of
things like that they don't have to
recycle Fox villains they have plenty of
their own cosmic entities to pull from
and that brings me to the second
possible direction for the Marvel phase
four going cosmic with each passing
phase in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the movies have gotten more and more
daring with expanding the boundaries of
its physical reality remember the first
Iron Man and Thor they ended with
one-on-one showdowns and quiet city
streets on earth now we got Doctor
Strange swiping through dimensions and
timelines like they're boring Instagram
photos ant-man is stuck collecting
mysterious healing particles from a
subatomic quantum realm Thor and Hulk
are blasting through devils anuses gross
weird legitimately studying concepts of
theoretical physics to try to predict
where these things are gonna go and by
studying I mean like Wikipedia and
infinity war was the craziest leap yet
right half the entire universe is dust
and judging from the comic series of
that movie was based on Thanos interacts
with several even larger cosmic godlike
creatures
there's Mephisto that's Marvel's version
of the devil he's basically by Thanos
decide the entire story Galactus gets
pissed off when this happens and he
joins beings like eternity eternity is
the living embodiment of the universe
itself Chronos the master of time and
the Living Tribunal the universe is
Almighty judge to try to hold Danos
responsible for his actions doesn't work
but any of these beings could be more
dangerous threats for the Avengers to
face because they're essentially gods
and while taking God's on might seem a
bit tough they might not be alone like
the more ivory watch infinity war the
clearer it becomes that Thanos is a true
hero that story the directors even said
that at one point they considered having
Thanos narrate the movie so imagine a
Marvel future where Thanos fights
alongside the war and the other
characters against one of those other
greater cosmic threats Josh Brolin could
play yet another cold-hearted Marvel
villain turned Ally
the MCU is already teased the existence
of such greater threats of course
Dormammu from the Dark Dimension and
Doctor Strange is still presumably alive
and well maybe a little pissed off at
strength tricked him with time dr.
strange rector scott derrickson hinted
that nightmare could be the villain of
the next movie
nightmares the evil entity from the
dream dimension who feeds off negative
human emotion and remember guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 is post-credits
introduced Adam warlocks of MCU he's
another godlike figure who plays a huge
role in the Infinity Gauntlet comics and
he is an evil opposite character named
Magus who would be another major comics
write of Marvel wants to use him but
what we're looking at figures already
introduced in the MCU that poses the
third possible direction for phase 4
returning to past MCU villains Dormammu
isn't the only MC villain still kicking
around Red Skull from the first Captain
America what's of course revealed to be
alive an infinity war and Ronan the
accuser of guardians of the galaxy will
play a role in the upcoming Captain
Marvel oh I think that's obviously gonna
be a flashback and unless timelines get
completely reset I think his time is
done interestingly there was that Easter
Egg week on spider-man homecoming where
Peter is rummaging through the
government storage and he finds an old a
Tron head it's red eyes appear to be
glowing which is how in age of Ultron
you could tell which Ultron drone
contained his consciousness that moment
maybe it's just a jokey Easter Egg or
maybe it's suggesting that Ultron's
consciousness still exists waiting to be
reawakened I'm just saying Ultron is a
pretty great Marvel Comics villain that
the movie could have done a lot more
with and the same goes for the Mandarin
from Iron Man 3 who was revealed to be a
charlatan Patsy but it's been hinted
that the real Mandarin could still exist
out there somewhere but really the
Mandarin feels like more of a
small-scale baddie
which brings us to our final direction
that Marvel could go for face forward
making things personal maybe instead of
expanding a universe in phase four
Marvel could condense it like focus in
with more personal anthology stories for
each of their heroes with villains that
correspond to their specific values
honestly this is where superheroes are
at their best good stories feature
heroes and villains that are
philosophical opposites of each other
Black Panther and kill monger The Dark
Knight and the Joker anyway Logan and
his empathy free self x24 it's kinda
hard to do this sort of thing with
universe-threatening cosmic villains
like Thanos but imagine a Black Widow
solo movie something we know isn't it
works in which she takes on a villain
like taskmaster who can mimic any attack
dealt to him blow over blow or a
spider-man sequel that brings Norman
Osborn into the MCU there have been some
theories out there that Oscorp could
take over the old Avengers Tower in
Manhattan now that it's vacated of
course Sony still owns all the
spider-man properties and they would
have to give special permission to
marble to
feature them in the movie but is looking
likely that far from home will feature
multiple spider-man villain making
things personal perhaps setting up a
sinister six in the MCU now do these
sound like a new foe threatens to
destroy them all who would replace
Thanos maybe not but villains can be
destructive in more emotional ways than
sticks and stones folks like maybe
Marvel can get my old grade school bully
to be its next villain she was the worst
who do you want to be the next major
villain of the MCU comment down below
with your thoughts and follow the new
rock stars on twitter and instagram at
new rockstars and for my takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at a
boss and subscribe to this channel for
more Marvel theories and breakdowns and
during this holiday season if you're
planning to write a mean comment down
below just remember that the next
villain could be you then come on